[Musique]
julie chouteau bonsoir bonsoir oserait
faire le tri entre les fossés les vraies
informations qui circulent sur le net
c'est votre tâche ce soir et vous
emmener sur un terrain privilégié des
faits que nous la guerre en ukraine
toujours oui ce soir audrey on va
répondre à une question d'un
téléspectateur d'ailleurs on l'en
remercie et je vous rappelle que si vous
aussi vous voulez que l'on vérifie une
information vous avez vu circuler sur
internet pour cela il suffit de nous
envoyer un message privé sur le compte
twitter que oui s'affiche elle un cran à
l'écran le quick le compte twitter d'un
faux intox info ou intox f24 tout
attaché alors aujourd'hui nous allons
donc nous intéresser à un tweet qui nous
est donc été envoyé par un
téléspectateur ce tweet il dit quoi il
dit qu'un célèbre tireurs d'élite
canadien surnommé ouali se serait engagé
volontairement en une crème un plus
particulièrement sur la ligne de front
de marioupol et qu'ils auraient été
tuées seulement 20 minutes après son
arrivée sur le front ukrainien est
effectivement à ce genre de publications
circule beaucoup sur internet et
particulièrement en afrique de l'ouest
certaines publications comme celle ci
présente même prétendent même montré
quel soldat russe a tué le sniper
canadien alors c'est tantôt un homme
comme ici où tantôt une femme selon les
publications alors déjà pour commencer
qui est ce tireur d'élite canadien alors
il s'appelle olivier de la vigne ortiz
plus connu sous le nom je voulais dit de
walle c'est un ex soldat de l'armée
canadienne avec laquelle il avait
combattu en afghanistan il s'est aussi
illustré en irak en combattant le groupe
etat islamique cette fois non pas au
sein de l'armée canadienne mais de son
propre chef comme volontaire auprès des
kurdes se tient hors d'élite est
d'ailleurs controversés comme le dit cet
article publié en 2016 sur radio-canada
pourquoi parce qu'il aime se mettre en
scène dans des publications de guerre et
récemment et bien ce style pur canadien
avait bien rejoint cette grillade la
brigade normandie c'est un groupe de
volontaires canadien donc partis
combattre les soldats russes en ukraine
et là encore de leur propre chef de
manière indépendante donc il s'est bien
rendu en ukraine sans le sait ce groupe
a d'ailleurs publié ce communiqué sur
facebook il est écrit d'ailleurs que
ouali le sniper canadien ne fait plus
partie de cette unité la brigade
normandie karine n'était pas toujours
les instructions en matière de
communication notamment mais surtout ce
que nous dit ce communiqué c'est que
ouali est bel et bien vivant aux
dernières nouvelles la formation qui
circulent sur sa mort un don qui est
donc complètement fausse et nous nous
avons aussi pu le vérifier ici à france
24 pourquoi puisque tout simplement
olivier lavigne orties saliao alias wali
nous a accordé une interview on écoute
ses six voiliers qui vous parle donc
contrairement à la rumeur donc je suis
pas du tout mort au combat non j'étais
pas à mario paul en fait je n'ai jamais
vu ça de ma vie
je suis dans la région de kiev et non
seulement je suis pas mort mais on
appris du terrain à l'ennemi russe alors
est ce qu on sait d'où provient cette
fête nous alors il semblerait que les
premières fausses informations faisant
état de la mort de cet homme sont
apparus sur des sites chinois qui cite
des sources russophone est en effet
comme vous le voyez un certain tweets
comme celui ci fonde mon train ces
messages publiés en chinois et ceux des
lames dès mars ils ont ensuite été
repris un peu partout dans différentes
langues quant au pourquoi de cette fête
news 1 quel est son but pourquoi avoir
fait croire à la mort de cet homme le
principal intéressé a sa propre idée on
écoute
l'effort dévalant talent comme moi donc
soit en leur faisant rapport à leurs
familles donc il faut s'imaginer que
imaginez-vous être une mère de famille
qui des nouvelles comme quoi très bons
tireurs d'élite expérimenté aurait dit
celui qui a presque immédiatement au
combat donc ça se pourrait que fassi
pression par exemple sur votre fils qui
dit vouloir y aller pour qu'il n'y ait
ni et pau 5 il me sort impôts en ukraine
alors je vous rappelle tout de même que
ces combattants volontaires sains comme
ce sniper canadien mais ils partent de
leur propre initiative initiative
extrêmement dangereuse a quand même
disons le est très critiquée puisqu'à
aucun moment ces volontaires ne
reçoivent ni l'aval ni la supervision de
l'armée de leur pays d'origine merci
beaucoup je lis shoot ou rester avec
nous on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour nous